one of the things that I'm truly most
proud of in my professional life is that
what we've done with the Reuben report
if you look at the youtube comments on
our videos they are really really on
point which is a credit to you guys and
i think has a little sign to do with
what I've tried to do with the show
which is give a couple different
opinions admit that I don't know
everything and and listen to you guys
when you say things because I think
knowing my audience helps me do better
and you know YouTube commenters get
blasted all the time for being racist
and homophobic men and leather but what
we've built on our videos is actually
I'd say ninety percent of the comments
they don't necessarily agree with me but
they're on point about what we're
talking about there's plenty of other
news channels and all kinds of things
that you can look at on YouTube and the
comments are just crazy trolling and
fighting so I'm really proud of what
we've done and I think part of that is
that what I try to do is if you see who
I the types of people that I follow on
Twitter or on other social media I
follow people that I agree with and
people that I don't agree with and I
think the real challenge of the media
going forward 2015 and for the next
couple years is that the challenge is
not only for the media but for us to
follow people that have opinions that
you don't necessarily agree with be
challenged by things you know if all day
long you're looking at your feed and
it's only reinforcing your opinions no
matter how right you may think you are
and I know we all like to think we're
right about everything all the time but
if you're only getting that reinforced
you're actually not really helping the
debate because what makes a good country
at a good world is people from all
different opinions and all different
walks of life and ethnicities and races
and colors and all that can come
together and create something new and I
think that we've gotten into this thing
where we just cater our news to
ourselves and its really really
dangerous because it's just gonna
strengthen one side your side but guess
what the guy on the other side is just
having his side strike that all the time
to really try to follow a couple things
I follow conservative sites i follow
liberal sides i follow things that are
complete conspiracy things just to kind
of get a taste of what is out there in
the world and I really really highly
recommend it and and also i highly
recommend you guys keep please keep
staying involved in what we're doing
here because we do pay attention to
comments and the questions that you're
asking and I try to respond to them and
all that so this is a thank you and
let's let's keep up the good work as
something Goods happening here